oh [ __ ]
oh my god i know
why do people do that
holy [ __ ]
that is crazy
khloe kardashian fights back tears
trying spicy wings on hot ones and yes
those were mascara tears but coco is a
freaking champ i'm just trying to make
it through the end of this yeah the
kardashian star puts her taste buds to
the test with shawn evans and things
seem to be going well at first okay
that's good
you're doing great okay you're doing so
good i think i got this oh wow there's a
kick after that okay
[Music]
but as they turn up the heat let's just
say things went a bit downhill genuinely
i cannot believe it the spice level
increases and coco starts to sweat
oh
right away
oh my god
oh you like the milk oh my god i know
why do people do this
holy i know i know it's a completely
different level
oh my god my heart's racing anyone
else's heart racing watching this
that is crazy
but that wasn't the hottest sauce khloe
tried props to our girl she made it to
the very last one
oh my god has anyone thrown up from that
never no you'd break new ground okay
khloe kardashian taking on the wings of
death and living to tell the tale i'm
just trying to make it through the end
of this
yep coco is a trooper and still looks
great even if she was pretty
uncomfortable there for a sec we all
want to be cute over here and when she
wasn't eating spicy wings she was
answering questions from your vantage
point as reality tv creator are there
things that you notice like how the
sausage has made details when you're
watching say the real housewives that
the rest of us may miss watching from
our couch after spending nearly her
entire adult life on reality tv coco
says she learned how to spot subtle
mistakes when she sees them on other
shows i can tell when
some audio has been put in if they need
to like reshoot audio or if like a phone
call is fake of course after 20 seasons
of keeping up with the kardashians
chloe's now on her fam's new series on
hulu the kardashians but this time
around she says she's handling things a
bit differently i think for every sister
we have different boundary levels and we
all try to respect that and but i think
and probably moving forward we might all
have and like your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later though i think moving
forward things might change with me but
who knows i am an open book and i like
to be that way
you